recently a texas cheerleading squad
called the indianettes came under fire
for chanting racist cheers during a
performance at disney world here to
comment is a high school cheerleading
squad
ready okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's great and all but i thought you
guys were going to deliver a response to
that cheerleading squad's terrible
actions that was our response oh
i get it well thank you for that
you're welcome
okay well you guys are here do you have
any other cheers you bet we do we're the
hottest cheerleaders in the game oh this
is like bring it on
never heard of it
oh never mind okay go ahead
ready
okay we may not have good rhythm we
cannot keep the beat but when i ask for
the manager you better take a seat
wait a second there's something weird
about your cheers what exactly is your
team name
we're the caronettes
the caronettes
like
the little karens
yes
i'll allow it please continue
ready
okay
our team is what red hat our team is one
but not too hot our team is one and hold
the stop our team is
[Applause]
you guys these cheers are delightful but
you're an all black squad how did you
start cheering for a team called the
karen's
redistricting
no further questions
you know
oh my gosh wait a second
along with your uniforms there are also
costumes
ready
okay i said ew
i taste white tears there must be some
carrots in the atmosphere i said damn
the police are here there must be some
karen's in the
oh
okay like i i don't know you guys it
seems to me like these cheers disparage
and stereotype an entire group of people
no way
we're just doing what teams with native
american mascots are doing yeah by
dressing as cheap imitations of parents
and referencing tired stereotypes about
cairns we're actually showing how much
we respect karen's
doesn't really seem respectful to me
sure it is that's why we say kevin's
attack after every cheer so they know
we're rooting for them
okay all right
you guys
you actually had me there for a minute
hey
do you mind if i try one sure
oh thank you
all right
you guys just go everywhere like that
just screaming and that's great
ready okay
so tell the other team watch out when
throw a tantrum
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you